bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur public sénat pour la
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement dans quelques instants nous
allons rejoindre l'hémicycle du sénat
pour suivre cette séance avec
aujourd'hui trois questions consacrée
aux retraites deux autres sur la réforme
des collectivités territoriales
également une question du sénateur
socialiste jean-pierre sueur sur le
fonctionnement de la justice donc
séances à venir dans quelques instants
et puis après ensemble on refait la
séance est une nouvelle émission que
public sénat vous propose à partir de
cet après midi sur ce nouveau plateau
installé dans la salle des conférences
c'est le salon qui est juste à côté de
l'hémicycle du sénat est bien ensemble
on va refaire la séance avec les
parlementaires les ministres qui vont
intervenir dans l'hémicycle ensemble
nous allons revenir sur les grands
thèmes de l'actualité aujourd'hui donc
tout de suite vous propose de rejoindre
l'hémicycle pour les questions
d'actualité et après retour ici sur le
plateau de public sénat
à tout à l'heure
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
travail monsieur le ministre du travail
nos compatriotes sont de plus en plus
nombreux à exprimer leur inquiétude et
leur mécontentement face à la réforme
des retraites que vous allez leur
imposer ce que vous appelez une réforme
et qu'il est qu une série d'ajustements
comptables est injuste brutale
inéquitable et inefficace injuste
monsieur le ministre car le recul de
l'âge légal de départ de 60 à 62 ans et
celui de la retraite à taux plein de 65
à 67 ans pénalise les salariés qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt pénalise ceux
qui ont travaillé longtemps ceux qui ont
alterné période de travail et période de
chômage travail à temps partiel
et là je pense particulièrement aux
femmes monsieur le ministre
maintenir le droit au départ en retraite
à 60 ans pour cela tout en permettant à
ceux qui le souhaitent et ceux qui le
peuvent de poursuivre leurs activités
seraient juste maintenir la pension à
taux plein à 65 ans sort est juste ce
projet de loi un brutal brutale parce
que contrairement à tous les autres pays
l'application de ces ajustements se fait
sur une durée très courte
là où on doit dialoguer concertée
construire avant de décider vous ou
plutôt le président de la république
décidé de passer en force ce projet est
inéquitable
parce que 85% des efforts exigés sont
exigés des salariés alors que les
revenus du capital le contribué qu'à
hauteur de 15% le capital doit être mis
à contribution
monsieur le ministre il pour augmenter
les prélèvements sociaux sur les bonus
et les stock options et remettre en
cause la défiscalisation des plus values
sur les cessions de filiales
ce projet de loi est inefficace il est
inefficace parce qu'il n'aurait alors
rien
équilibre financier de notre régime de
retraite malgré le scandale le
siphonnage du fonds de réserve des
retraites
il ne règle rien non plus et en aucune
manière la question de l'emploi des
seniors et des jeunes vous ne les
rencontre est donc pas monsieur le
ministre c'est gens condamnés au chômage
parce que leur entreprise estime qu'il
coûte trop cher je sais ce que vous
allez me répondre monsieur le ministre
vous allez me répondre qu'il s'agit de
sauver notre régime notre système de
retraite par répartition
avez vous mesuré l'inquiétude grondante
de nos concitoyens et en particulier des
plus jeunes qui n'ont plus aucune
confiance dans l'avenir
quel message monsieur le ministre des
situations peuvent ils encore espérer de
vous
mais pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur minery travail de solidarité au
public vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président ce
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs même la sénatrice bon on va
parler de tout cela pendant pendant plus
de 15 jours au sénat donc on ira
jusqu'au fond du débat et je pense que
peut-être plus si c'est plus tant mieux
moi je suis favorable au débat je suis
persuadé que vous ferez vivre je suis je
serai persuadé d'ailleurs que vous ferez
vivre ce débat au sénat
le quand vous dites même de nom thèse
quand vous dites que nous faisons des
ajustements comptables j'imagine que
dans votre bouche c'est pas très aimable
mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on ne peut pas se contenter d'un
système de retraites en france qui
accumule les déficits
évidemment et j'imagine que vous ne le
souhaitez pas non plus on la crise a
augmenté la crise a rapproché de 20 ans
les déficits de nos régimes de retraites
il faut bien en face de cela qui une
réponse appropriée du gouvernement et
c'est ce que nous faisons est la
première des justices la première des
justices d'un système de retraites c'est
d'être en équilibre
un système de retraite en déséquilibre
si à ce moment-là rendre plus fragiles
celles et ceux qui le sont c'est à dire
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas eu la
capacité financière de mettre de
l'argent de côté et ils sont très
nombreux en france le système de
retraite français
c'est un système de retraite par
répartition
la répartition c'est la solidarité entre
les générations et donc il est bien
logique même de l'ontt s il est bien
logique de considérer que ce sont
d'abord les travailleurs pas les
salariés les travailleurs qui financent
le système par répartition ce que vous
évoquez au travers de votre logique
c'est un système par capitalisation
la wii ce que vous dites pourrait être
vrai mais madame nous voulons un système
par répartition c'est à dire un système
financé par des actifs ce sont les
actifs de l'année qui paye les retraites
des retraités
c'est notre pacte social c'est notre
lien social c'est ce qui est issu
du conseil national de la résistance et
si là dessus que nous sommes fondés à
réformer notre système de retraite
enfin notre système est juste et il est
profondément juste ça veut dire que les
personnes qui ont commencé plus tôt à
travailler ont la capacité de partir
plus tôt mais ça ne gênait pas le parti
socialiste même de mon test quand vous
avez créé la retraite à 60 ans en deux
en 1982 savent où je n'aime pas que les
gens travaillent 46 ans savent où je
n'ai pas quelqu'un qui avait trait à
commencé à travailler à 14 ans
travaillent jusqu'à 60 ans 46 ans de
cotisation vous ne vous êtes pas posé
cette question nous d'y répondre
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant président guy fischer pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
des sénateurs du parti de gauche avaient
la parole monsieur le président monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre du
travail mes chers collègues votre
réforme des retraites est massivement
rejeté 70% des français exigent le
maintien à 60 ans à taux plein reste
attaché à la répartition et disent non à
la capitalisation 68% ont soutenu la
dernière journée de mobilisation
votre électorat vous abandonne la
tentative d'imposer la réforme dans des
esprits durant l'été a échoué
c'est une bien mauvaise surprise pour
nicolas sarkozy et l'ump
pressé par le temps inquiet de la
mobilisation croissante dans le pays
vous êtes passé en force à l'assemblée
nationale aidé par un président aux
ordres de l'elysée
monsieur le ministre le scénario ne sera
pas le même au sénat qui n'a pas adopté
le règlement scélérat de l'assemblée
nationale qui bafoue les droits de
l'opposition
on ne le répétera jamais assez cette
réforme est injuste et inefficace
supporter à 85% par les salariés et
marginalement par les revenus du capital
c'est cette justice cette injustice
criante qui a fait basculer l'opinion
publique
notre peuple sait en effet que l'argent
existe pour financer les retraites
monsieur le ministre vous avez tenté
jusqu'au bout de masquer cette évidence
économique et financière mais la sphère
béthoncourt ne vous a pas aidés la
volonté du gouvernement et de l'ump de
flatter et de protéger les plus riches
est devenue une réalité palpable par nos
compatriotes la collusion du pouvoir et
de l'argent deviennent évidence la
jeunesse à temps c'est très fort non
elle la rejette car cette réforme
supprime de fait le droit à la retraite
pour les jeunes la démographie l'exigent
non car la france a un taux de natalité
qui permet de voir l'avenir sereinement
l'europe nous a précédés c'est mal
connaître la réalité car les conditions
de travail et de départ à la retraite
sont plus protectrice chez de nombreux
voisins
les caisses sont vides non celle du
patronat et des banques sont pleines
vous voulez faire payer aux peuples la
cupidité des banques et d'un cac 40 dont
les profits explosent
là est le coeur du problème d'autres
moyens existent sur l'utilisation
efficace des revenus du capital pour
financer les retraites à 60 ans à taux
plein nous avons déposé une proposition
de loi en ce sens tu réalises invitons
le gouvernement à eau propre
connaissance
le gouvernement doit retirer son projet
et ouvrir des négociations qui n'ont pas
eu lieu
merci de ce président bien le carré
blanc était trop la parole pour vous
répondre et au ministre du travail
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président fischer les autres pays
ont-ils toujours tort est ce que les
allemands est ce que les anglais est ce
que les italiens ce que les espagnols
est-ce que les suédois ont
nécessairement tort lorsqu'il repousse
l'âge de la retraite
c'est une question moi je veux
1 je veux bien que je veux bien que vous
mettiez des affiches avec marquez
retraite à 60 ans sauf que évidemment
c'est facile de faire ça c'est de
l'électoralisme
c'est de la démagogie c'est pas c'est
pas autre chose
la retraite la retraite c'est un pl
c'est une d'abord une question d'âge la
retraite c'est une question d'espérance
de vie
la retraite si au fond le temps que l'on
se donne
lorsqu'on a travaillé pour après pouvoir
bénéficier d'un peu de temps pour soi
même et ce temps il doit augmenter et il
augmente aujourd'hui on reste plus
longtemps en retraite qu'auparavant et
avec la retraite à 62 ans restera encore
plus de temps qu'auparavant
simplement parce que l'âge augmente et
vous n'avez pas le droit et vous n'avez
pas le droit d'une certaine manière de
toujours vouloir mettre au à la charge
des générations qui viennent ce que nos
générations n'accepterait pas nous
devons être responsables devant un sujet
comme cela et les actifs les actifs dans
un régime par répartition monsieur le
président fischer vous le savez et vous
tenez à ce régime comme nous tenons à ce
régime c'est bien les actifs
c'est-à-dire les travailleurs qui payent
la retraite des retraités
et lorsque nous ajoutons des recettes
fiscales
nous ajoutons 4 milliards d'euros de
recettes fiscales ce n'est pas pour
financer la répartition c'est pour
financer la solidarité dans la
répartition car il est là car il est
logique de considérer que tout ce qui
relève de la solidarité doit relever des
impôts et nous le faisons au travers de
4 milliards de fiscalité supplémentaire
sur les plus aisés
alors vous nous dites que c'est injuste
mais est-il injuste de laisser nos
compatriotes qui souffrent de pénibilité
partir plus tôt non je crois que c'est
juste et il a juste de considérer quand
on a commencé à travailler tôt à 14 ans
à 15 ans à 16 ans à 17 ans est-ce que
c'est injuste de considérer qu'on peut
partir plus tôt c'est-à-dire à 60 ans à
la retraite est il a juste de considérer
que les fonctionnaires qui sont en
catégorie active peuvent partir plus tôt
c'est ce que nous faisons sur le
président dans cette
et forme alors oui c'est une réforme
difficile c'est plus difficile c'est
plus difficile de faire une réforme de
retraite que de ne jamais en faire comme
la gauche n'a jamais fait
merci messieurs menu la parole est
maintenant aux présidents jacques
legendre pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur luc chatel
ministre de l'éducation nationale et
porte-parole du gouvernement et concerne
les objectifs du programme clair depuis
la rentrée 2010 le programme clair
collèges et lycées pour l'ambition
l'innovation et la réussite est
expérimenté dans les établissements
concentrant le plus de difficultés tant
d'un point de vue de la réussite que du
climat scolaire et malheureusement de la
violence il concerne en l'état
105 collèges et lycées et sera étendu à
la rentrée 2011 à la mesure de l'enjeu
les objectifs de ce programme sont
ambitieux il s'agit tout à la fois
d'améliorer sensiblement le climat
scolaire de renforcer la stabilité des
équipes et de faciliter la réussite de
chacun aussi ce programme des fentes il
une approche de nature à répondre aux
défis de l'enseignement secondaire la
volonté de replacer l'élève au coeur des
préoccupations en est la composante
essentielle laquelle se réalise avec la
définition du projet d'orientation de
l'élève en lien avec le parcours de
découverte des métiers et des formations
le succès d'un tel projet dépend
également nous le savons de la
motivation de l'implication de la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs de la
communauté scolaire qui seront associés
à l'élaboration de règles communes de
vie indispensable
l'évaluation du programme clair implique
que chaque établissement qui le suit
signe un contrat d'objectifs
avec les autorités académiques un
accompagnement par les corps
d'inspection est ainsi prévue avec la
désignation par le recteur d'un
inspecteur d'académie inspecteur
pédagogique régional référent pour
chacun des établissements concernés
ce programme pour qu'il réponde
pleinement à sa vocation suppose une
plus grande autonomie des équipes
pédagogiques
selon mesure d'apporter à des problèmes
spécifiques les réponses adaptées
pouvez vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre qu'on va se concrétiser cette
autonomie dont le but est d'assurer la
réussite nécessaire des élèves au
répondre le président le journe parole
est à monsieur luc chatel ministre de
l'éducation nationale porte-parole du
gouvernement vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président le gendre pour permettre la
réussite de chaque élève le système
éducatif français est confronté
aujourd'hui à deux défis celui de la
personnalisation de notre enseignement
être capable d'adapter notre
enseignement à la diversité de nos
élèves
et puis le défi de l'autonomie c'est à
dire faire confiance au local faire
confiance à ceux qui connaissent le
mieux nos élèves et la personnalisation
et l'autonomie constitue le fil
conducteur des réformes que nous avons
engagées en primaire avec l'aide
personnalisée qui est apporté deux
heures par semaine aux élèves qui ont
des difficultés de lecture au lycée en
cette rentrée avec les deux heures
d'accompagnement personnalisé où on
prend les élèves à part pour leur
apporter une approche particulière sur
mesure mais nous savons en même temps et
vous l'avez rappelé que dans les
établissements qui suscite plus
d'inquiétude qui concentre le plus de
difficultés il faut faire davantage et
donc nous avons décidé dans 105 collèges
et lycées issus de zones de l'éducation
prioritaire avec des élèves en grande
difficulté
nous avons décidé d'aller plus loin en
matière d'autonomie dans le cadre
expérimental triple autonomie autonomie
pédagogique avec un projet qui sera
véritablement adapté aux élèves
qui sont dans ces établissements avec un
enseignement transdisciplinaire avec la
volonté d'aménager les rythmes scolaires
pour coller au plus près du besoin
deuxièmement autonomie en matière de
recrutement des personnels
le chef d'établissement pourra recruter
ces personnels d'enseignement sur profil
c'est à dire sur la base du volontariat
de ses équipes pédagogiques
c'est très important que ces professeurs
soient volontaires soient motivés et
s'engage sur un minimum de durer dans
ses établissements au moins cinq années
et puis enfin autonomie en matière de
climat d' au sein de l'établissement
avec la nomination d'un préfet des
études qui aura pour objectif d'assurer
le lien avec les familles de faire en
sorte que le climat soit meilleur au
sein de l'établissement qui sera chargée
auprès du chef d'établissement de
l'organisation et du suivi de la vie
scolaire dont vous le voyez monsieur le
président le gendre nous avons un
dispositif expérimental que nous
évaluerons mais qui laisse une large
part à l'autonomie notre système
éducatif pour réussir a besoin de plus
de marge de manoeuvre de faire davantage
confiance aux acteurs locaux
c'est ce que nous faisons avec ce
programme clair merci monsieur ministre
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue françois fortassin pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre elle concerne les
droits du parlement
notre hôte ressembler les collectivités
territoriales collectivités dont nous
assurons parieurs en qualité de sénateur
la représentation comme l'indiqué
l'article 24 de la constitution la
réforme
je ne veux pas l'aborder sur le fond
dans le temps qui m'est en perte même
parti mais sur la forme une colère et
une craie forme des collectivité
peut-elle se faire contre le sénat
pourtant mon départ les choses avaient
bien commencé il y avait eu la mission
belot qui avait thème qui s'était
déplacé sur le terrain'' qui avaient
certes suscité quelques inquiétudes mais
aussi beaucoup d'espérance il y a eu un
rapport consensuel quasi consensuelle
par la suite ce rapport boulot qui était
pourtant remarquable a été foulée aux
pieds
suscitant inquiétudes et déception à
partir d'un texte extravagant est
surréaliste
le sénat a toutefois essayé d'améliorer
les choses
par un travail en profondeur avec un
grand principe sauvegarde et l'autonomie
de chacune des collectivités locales de
chaque strate de collectivités locales
le projet adopté par l'assemblée
nationale est très éloignée de la
version votée au sénat les sénateurs
sont dépités résigner pour les plus
dociles et particulièrement en colère
pour les autres j'ai dit
particulièrement colère pour les autres
en réalité le sénat est humiliée et
piétiné dans cette affaire-là
alors monsieur le premier ministre
connaît bien le fonctionnement sénat
comme je le connais le président mercier
ministre maintenant en charge de
l'aménagement du territoire alors vous
l'a demandé le président colin par un
courrier auquel vous n'avez pas encore
répondu vous avez deux possibilités soit
provoqué la mise en place ne sème paix
laissant a le poignet le parlementaire
triés sur le volet la possibilité de
s'ils voulaient conclure r je fantasme
tout faire le travail sur une réforme
qui touche en profondeur à
l'organisation décentralisée de la
république soit de laisser se poursuivre
la navette pour une troisième lecture
pour vous répondre la parole est
précisément à michel mercier ministre de
l'espace rural et de l'aménagement du
territoire il avait la parole monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président du
sénat mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur forte à ça je vous
remercie d'abord pour questions que vous
n'êtes posé qui est extrêmement
intéressantes parfois avec un peu
d'excès mai mais si peu mais si peu je
veux d'abord rappelé que cette réforme
est une réforme particulièrement
importante et le gouvernement a pris
grand soin et qu'elles ne se fassent pas
de façon précipitée il y à eut d'abord
comme vous l'avez rappelé le rapport
boulot il y avait également les travaux
de la commission que préside m monsieur
balladur et dès le premier semestre 2008
le gouvernement a pris soin de consulter
toutes les associations d'élus toutes
les associations d'élus ont été
consultés ensuite il y a eu deux
lectures dans chacune des chambres et je
voudrais vous rappeler mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs depuis la
réforme de la constitution
le sénat ne se prononce plus sur le
texte du gouvernement
mais sur le texte de la commission et il
ya eu également quatre délibérations des
deux commissions concernées il y a donc
eu un très long débat près de 300 heures
de débat parlementaire
près de 300 heures de débats
parlementaires ont été consacrés à la
réforme des collectivités locales ce qui
est tout à fait exceptionnel les deux
assemblées ont d'ailleurs très bien
travaillé puisque il y à de très
nombreux
dispositions qui ont été acceptés qui
ont été acceptées par les deux chambres
de façon conforme l'essentiel je veux
rappeler par exemple que la création du
conseiller territorial a été votée par
l'assemblée nationale et par le sénat et
que tout ce qui est relatif à
l'intercommunalité a été largement voté
de façon conforme par l'assemblée
nationale et sénat
et c'est vrai qu'il reste des points de
désaccord qui sont importants qui sont
importants essentiellement le mode
d'élection du conseiller territorial
je rappelle que l'assemblée nationale a
pris une position claire et que le sénat
par trois votes successifs a
successivement rejeté tous les modes de
scrutin
il appartiendra maintenant dans la suite
de la discussion parlementaire a terminé
et la mise au point est de tous ces
articles
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant hervé maurey notre collègue
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
jamais la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
l'assemblée nationale a adopté
avant-hier le projet de loi portant
réforme des collectivités territoriales
de manière assez surprenante
elle a en seulement quelques heures fait
table rase du travail accompli par le
sénat pendant plus de soixante heures de
débat au cours desquelles nous avions
fait en sorte de prendre en compte les
inquiétudes et les aspirations des élus
locaux des territoires dont nous sommes
les représentants de l'avis unanime des
élus locaux de toutes tendances
confondues nous avions fait du bon
travail
comment dans ce contexte ne pas
s'étonner du mépris dont les députés ont
fait preuve à l'égard de la haute
assemblée
comment ne pas s'étonner que les députés
de l'opposition n'ait pas jugé bon de
prendre part aux débats sur un texte
aussi important
alors qu'ils ne se privent pas sur le
terrain de susciter les inquiétudes des
élus locaux avec des informations
erronées
au terme de cet examen par l'assemblée
nationale
le mode de scrutin du conseiller
territorial rejeté par le sénat a été
rétablie les compétences et les
financements ont été également rétabli
les dispositions concernant le cumul des
mandats ont été supprimés le tableau des
conseillers territoriaux que nous avions
adopté a été largement revu les
améliorations apportées à la parité ont
été supprimés
le dispositif relatif aux communes
nouvelles modifié au point d'être à
nouveau source d'inquiétude pour les
communes
dans une interview du 12 août 2010 au
figaro notre président gérard larcher
déclaré qu'il ne souhaitait pas que le
gouvernement convoque une commission
mixte paritaire préférant je le cite que
le processus parlementaire aille à son
terme
aussi je voudrais savoir monsieur le
ministre si le gouvernement entend
laisser le processus parlementaire aller
à son terme ou convoquer une commission
mixte paritaire
je voudrais savoir si vous considérez
qu'un texte concernant les collectivités
territoriales peut être adoptée par la
seule assemblée nationale ne serait-il
pas dans ce cas pour reprendre
l'expression du président du sénat
quelque peu fragile ne serait ce pas
comme nous le pensons un très mauvais
signal envoyé aux collectivités locales
que d'adopter un texte les concernant
sans l'accord de l'assemblée chargée de
les représenter enfin monsieur le
ministre
quelles initiatives comprendre le
gouvernement pour que nous n'arrivions
pas à cette situation
pour vous répondre la parole et monsieur
michel mercier ministre de la ruralité
et de l'aménagement du territoire
monsieur le président du sénat mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur maurey j'aime bien
j'ai bien compris votre question
d'autant plus que vous avez activement
participé au débat sénatorial sur ce
texte
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un vrai débat et
qu'il y a eu des progressions dans ce
débat et qu'on a vu petit à petit se
dégager des consensus entre les deux
chambres sur le conseiller territorial
je le rappelle c'est la pierre angulaire
de la réforme que désormais le même élu
siège au conseil général et au conseil
régional
c'est très naturellement quelque chose
de nouveau c'est ma réponse
ensuite il y a eu tout à fait de travail
de fond fait par les deux chambres sur
tout ce qui concerne l'intercommunalité
plus de 300 heures de débat
parlementaire ont été organisés sur ce
sujet le gouvernement souhaite tout à
fait qu'il y ait un accord entre les
deux assemblées qui peut être dégagée
dans une forme prévue par la
constitution et c'est ce qui va arriver
il appartiendra donc dans quelques
instants au premier ministre de faire
connaître la position du gouvernement au
président du sénat et au président de
l'assemblée nationale sur ce point le
gouvernement ira jusqu'au bout du
dialogue souhaite qu'il y ait sur ce
texte
un accord entre les deux chambres et que
la loi portant réforme des collectivités
territoriales
soit votée par l'assemblée nationale et
par le sénat
il n'ya pas pour nous de volonté qu'une
assemblée impose sa vision à une autre
et le gouvernement fera tout ce qui est
en son pouvoir pour qu'on arrive à un
accord entre les deux chambres
merci monsieur le ministre tout est
clair
doc la parole dès maintenant notre
collègue andré vantomme pour le groupe
socialiste
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président madame et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la question s'adresse à
monsieur baroin monsieur le ministre
voilà bientôt une décennie que la droite
est au pouvoir
aujourd'hui 13 % des ménages français
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté et 7
s'améliore pas votre politique en ce qui
concerne le logement secteur de
compétence de l'état est à nos yeux
caractérisée par des actes
répréhensibles successifs le braquage
des crédits mobiliers délester d'une
bonne partie leurs moyens d'abord puis
le hold up sur les ressources du 1%
logement
le racket pour trois ans pratiqués sur
les occupants des logements hlm
astreints par l'intermédiaire des
bailleurs sociaux à verser à l'état
340 millions d'euros soit 80 euros par
an et par locataire vous en conviendrez
avec nous monsieur le ministre la
politique que vous et votre majorité
menés n'inclut pas d'à que positif pour
résoudre la crise du logement
elle est plutôt le signe évident de la
politique d'un état impécunieux qui n'a
plus le sou a consacré à une mission
pourtant essentielle qui lui revient
faire vivre le droit au logement
vous nous diraient le contraire mais les
résultats sont là marquée par la
dégringolade de la construction depuis
plusieurs raids
pourtant les experts nous disent qu'il
nous faudrait construire 500 mille
logements nouveaux par an pour espérer
sortir de la crise d'ici cinq ans on
verra bien on reverra
l' approche des fêtes de fin d'année et
des froids hivernaux vous apitoyer sur
le sort de celles et ceux qui restent
sans toit et qu'on veut bien hébergés
pour la nuit seulement dans des
structures dites adapté l'examen
attentif du budget du logement que vous
proposez au parlement concrétisera mon
discours pas de moyens suffisants pas
d'ambition mais des artifices et des
faux-semblants
ainsi va la france sous le règne de
nicole les riches continueront d'être
abrité par le bouclier fiscal
les pauvres resteront pour certains trop
mou et posez votre question sans toit
pour cible pour abriter et si par la
chance ils en ont un il leur faudra y
consacrer toujours plus de leurs maigres
ressources alors monsieur le ministre
quand il y aura t-il dans votre
politique davantage d'équité et
d'humanisme vis-à-vis des plus précaires
quand prendrez-vous la mesure de
l'indécence de maintenir le bouclier
fiscal contours demande toujours plus
aux plus modestes
les locataires les bailleurs sociaux
liste ici et les entreprises du bâtiment
vous écouteront avec attention quand
vous répandre la parole est à monsieur
françois baroin ministre du budget des
comptes publics et de la réforme de
l'état vous avez la parole du ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur à la question quand il y aura
tjrs véritable politique du logement
quand vous regarderez attentivement le
projet de loi de finances 2011 qui est
dans la continuité de tous les budgets
préparer au cours des années précédentes
retenez un chiffre au cours des 15
dernières années le soutien dans le cas
des politiques publiques de l'état au
logement représentait bon an mal an 800
millions à un milliard cette année il
sera porté à deux milliards 6 vous
pouvez prendre le problème dans tous les
sens ce chiffre il explique le soutien
actif du gouvernement la construction de
logements deuxième élément vous
m'interrogez sur la mesure concernant
les hlm
c'est une curieuse conception et c'est
un biais très orienté qui souligne notre
engagement politique de considérer que
les bailleurs sociaux sont propriétaires
de l'argent dont la seule finalité est
d'améliorer le caractère des logements
sociaux pour les personnes qui en ont le
plus besoin
- que faites-vous ainsi des 10 milliards
dead fiscal c'est-à-dire des dépenses de
l'état sous forme de prêts bonifiés la
caisse des dépôts sous forme
d'exonération sur les sociétés sous
forme d'exonération sur les taxes
foncières que faites vous des 5
milliards d'apl qui permettent justement
de réduire d'un tiers les loyers que les
bailleurs sociaux proposent à leurs
locataires
et s'agissant de cette mesure que défend
avec courage à l'heure actuelle le
secrétaire d'état au logement monsieur
apparu nous avons tous les arguments et
nous sommes prêts a été montré pour
justifier que la proposition du
gouvernement est de mobiliser la
trésorerie dormantes qui représente 6
milliards et demi des bailleurs sociaux
aux fins prioritaire d'une part du
renouvellement urbain à travers le
financement de l'anru
d'autre part à la construction des
logements locatif à vocation sociale
il y a 6 milliards et demi de trésorerie
l'objectif c'est de permettre à ses
bailleurs sociaux dont la mission
essentielle est je le rappelle
d'accompagner la politique immobilière
et sociale soit les collectivités
territoriales soit de l'état pour
répondre à un objectif simple qui est
d'avoir des loyers modérés pour des gens
qui ne peuvent pas se loger ailleurs
dernier élément vous ne pourrez pas
faire campagne politique dans les villes
accompagnés par quelques acteurs de ces
bailleurs sociaux sur le thème à cause
du gouvernement les loyers vont
augmenter car justement le gouvernement
proposera au parlement au moment du
débat parlementaire et budgétaire de
bloquer l'augmentation des loyers en
fixant par la loi justement une
obligation et non pas comme les années
passées une incitation n'en vous
déplaise c'est la vérité merci luminy la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
bernard fournier pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire de la parole
mon cher collègue
oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues mais question s'adresse à
monsieur michel mercier ministre de
l'espace rural et de l'aménagement du
territoire monsieur le ministre à
l'issue des assises des territoires
ruraux
neuf des principaux opérateurs publics
français se sont réunis pour signer avec
l'état une convention de partenariat les
services publics avec
objectif d'accompagner le développement
des territoires ruraux où il faut le
signaler
la population commence à croître cette
augmentation est en particulier due aux
ménages actifs qui ont quitté les
grandes agglomérations pour s'installer
dans les zones rurales où naturellement
la pression foncière est moins forte à
tel enseigne d'ailleurs qu'une étude de
l'insee entre 2002 et 2007 a montré que
c'est dans les petites communes de
l'espace rural que les revenus
augmentent le plus vite
cependant naturellement les revenus
médians à campagne restent inférieurs à
ceux des villes on recense aujourd'hui
en france trente mille six cent quarante
quatre communes rurales lesquels
couvrent comme vous le savez monsieur le
ministre
82 % du territoire et regroupe 25 % de
la population alors qu'un habitant sur
quatre vit dans une commune rurale
on ne compte qu'un établissement
commercial sur six est un salarié sur
dix dans les communes rurales ainsi la
valorisation des territoires ruraux
notamment les plus oubliées les moins
bien desservis garde tout son sens
il s'agit comme l'a souhaité le
président de la république lors de son
discours à morée en février dernier de
permettre à nos concitoyens vivent hors
des villes de bénéficier d'un maximum de
services publics
en mutualisant les moyens des grands
opérateurs vous avez
vous avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
que l'expérimentation de ce projet puis
sa généralisation ferait l'objet d'un
contrat local de même que les préfets
des départements concernés détermineront
avec les opérateurs les collectivités
locales volontaires les actions et les
lieux d'amélioration des services
publics
pouvez vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre quels sont les critères retenus
pour mener à bien cette expérimentation
dont bien entendu nous nous félicitons
dont être pour vous répondre le plan
local monsieur michel mercier ministre
de l'espace rural et de l'aménagement du
territoire devait la parole du ministre
bercy le président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
monsieur sénateurs fournier c'est vrai
que nous assistons à un nouveau
phénomène notre pays depuis quelques
années c'est celui du renouveau des
territoires ruraux
vous non plus donc tout ça va bien à 6 1
je crois que c'est un phénomène nouveau
et pendant très longtemps nous avons
accompagné le déclin de ces territoires
il s'agit maintenant d'organiser leur
renouveau et ce renouveau
ce renouveau des territoires ruraux
retrouves persuadant les chiffres vous
l'avez rappelé les derniers recensements
ont montré et que globalement même si il
y à des situations contrastées suivant
les départements que globalement les
territoires ruraux ont gagné en
pourcentage 3 7 % d'habitants le même
pourcentage d'ailleurs que pour les
territoires urbains
il faut donc répondre à l'attenté des
habitants de ce territoire
c'était l'objet du travail mené dans les
assises des territoires ruraux et du
siat que le premier ministre a présidé
au mois de mai dernier et ce matin avec
henri de raincourt et brice hortefeux
nous avons accompagné le président de la
république dans l'yonne à montillot pour
saluer ce renouveau des territoires
la semaine dernière nous avons mis au
point un protocole avec neuf opérateurs
grands opérateurs de services au public
et ces opérateurs sont confortés par la
présence de la caisse des dépôts et
consignations et par l'association un
des pimms il s'agit d'expérimenter dans
22 départements métropolitains et un
départements d'outre-mer une
mutualisation et des services et au vu
des résultats de cette mutualisation de
généraliser le plus rapidement est cette
mutualisation sur tous les territoires
ruraux
l'état a dégagé des moyens financiers 15
millions d'euros deux effets d'un d'été
sont mises en place pour cette
expérimentation
chaque opérateur participera
financièrement les préfets de
département dès la semaine prochaine
prendront la tâche des élus locaux et
des représentants des opérateurs dans
les départements pour mettre au point
ces contrats locaux d'expérimentation et
de préparer leur généralisation
merci luccioni la parole est maintenant
madame catherine procaccia pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole monsieur recoller
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres monsieur le ministre luc
chatel
l'an passé dans le cadre de la loi sur
la formation professionnelle tout au
long de la vie en votant l'obligation de
rémunérer les stages de plus de deux
mois
nous avons voulu protéger des étudiants
des abus qui permettait à certaines
entreprises d'utiliser une manoeuvre de
haut niveau gratuite et consentante la
loi évoqué la notion de stages intégrés
dans un cursus universitaire et la
publication d'un décret immédiatement
certaines universités par trop prudentes
ont refusé de délivrer les attestations
dans la tente du décret résultat
plusieurs centaines si ce n'est un
millier d'étudiants ont été privés d'une
expérience dont ils ont besoin pour
préparer leur diplôme et pour leur
insertion dans la vie professionnelle
un groupe de quatre mille étudiants
c'est ainsi spontanément formés sur un
réseau social
attirer notre attention dès janvier j'ai
alerté la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur qui très vite a écrit au
président de l'université
mais de nombreux étudiants ont perdu le
stage qu'ils avaient eu tant de mal à
obtenir dans une entreprise
faute de voir fournit en temps la
précieuse convention le décret a été
publié le 26 août
il est applicable dès cette rentrée il
me paraissait clair à moi qui fut la
présidente de la commission spéciale sur
la formation professionnelle mais il
donne déjà lieu à des interprétations
variable selon les universités des
étudiants m'ont transmis des cas
concrets ses refus répétés pour obtenir
une convention leur donne le sentiment
d'être vraiment pénalisés car ces stages
sont le seul et vrai moyen de se
préparer au monde professionnel lorsque
l'on fait des études longues
monsieur minutes je vous demande
aujourd'hui de bien vouloir préciser
sous quelles conditions les étudiants de
licence de master 1 ou 2 peuvent
effectuer un stage d'études qu'il soit
obligatoire ou optionnel comme le
prévoit le décret
quel recours ont-ils si leur université
refusent d'établir cette convention pour
un stage intégré dans un cursus
optionnel parfois même demandé par un
professeur est particulièrement s'il
s'agit d'un stage de réorientation enfin
que comptez-vous faire à l'encontre des
officines qui profitant du flou de notre
loi abusent de la détresse des étudiants
en vendant des conventions de stage
merci une sur collègues pour vous
répondre la parole était un monsieur luc
chatel ministre de l'éducation nationale
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame le
sénateur processia je voudrais tout
d'abord excusé valérie pécresse qui ne
pouvaient pas être présents de cet après
midi qui m'a chargé de vous répondre
vous savez ma l'impro cassia
l'importance que le gouvernement attache
au stage j'allais dire aux stages dans
tous les cursus et c'est en effet le
stage un élément absolument
irremplaçables de la formation mais
aussi de l'insertion professionnelle
de nos jeunes diplômés alors c'est vrai
que la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur a été saisi par plusieurs
étudiants qui se sont vu refuser par
certaines universités
le conventionnement des stages qu'il
souhaitait faire pour compléter leur
formation et ce au prétexte que ces
stages était facultatif ces universités
s'appuierait sur le décret que vous avez
cités madame progression d'août 2010 qui
interdit effectivement les stages hors
cursus pour refuser tout stage qui ne
figureraient pas comme obligatoire dans
les maquettes de diplômes
je vous le dis très clairement madame le
sénateur il s'agit d'une interprétation
erronée des textes et l'application de
ces textes ne doit en aucun cas conduire
à restreindre l'accès aux stages des
étudiants volontaires et qui ont
vraiment besoin de ces stages pour
élargir leurs compétences et pour
approfondir leur formation alors
naturellement ces stages doivent être
encadrés faire l'objet d'une convention
d'un échange entre l'université et
l'entreprise de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent être valorisés dans le parcours
des étudiants
une circulaire et dont en cours au
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur de
manière à rappeler tous ces éléments et
valérie pécresse on a d'ailleurs déjà
informé les présidents d'université vous
avez également appelé mon attention sur
la question des officines
celles ci sont absolument inacceptables
et vous souvenez c'est d'ailleurs pour
lutter contre de telles dérives que nous
avons décidé d'interdire les stages hors
cursus dans le cas de la loi que vous
avez rappelé parce que ces pratiques
sont scandaleuses
elles sont contraires au code du travail
et elles doivent être combattues sans
relâche
valérie pécresse a rappelé à plusieurs
reprises la réglementation en la matière
vous souvenez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que le gouvernement s'est
battu d'abord pour que les étudiants
obtiennent une
cette rétribution sous forme d'une
gratification pour ces stages
ce qui n'était pas systématiquement le
cas vous souvenez ensuite que le
gouvernement s'est battu contre des
pratiques qui n'avait rien à voir avec
ces stages et bien soyez sûr madame
procas ya que valérie pécresse veillera
à ce que tous les étudiants inscrits
dans ces cursus bénéficie effectivement
de stage qui se lit ni la parole est
maintenant madame isabelle debré pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
que vaut la parole monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur eric woerth ministre du travail
de la solidarité et de la fonction
publique
monsieur le ministre alors que notre
assemblée s'apprête à débattre la
semaine prochaine du projet de loi
portant réforme des retraites la
condition les femmes est l'objet de
débats sur la place qui leur est faite
au sein du monde du travail
en la matière la majorité a de manière
constante affirmé sa volonté de répondre
aux inquiétudes justifiées qui s'exprime
à ce sujet exposé plus que la moyenne au
chômage à la précarité et aux inégalités
de traitement les femmes sont exposées à
un grand nombre de difficultés
spécifiques qu aucun des gouvernements
en place depuis 2002 n'a négligé
c'est ainsi que nous avons votée en 2006
une loi relative à l'égalité salariale
entre les hommes et les femmes
définissant le cadre qui doit nous
conduire à supprimer les écarts de
rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes ainsi que les mesures tendant à
remédier aux inégalités constatées de ce
point de vue il apparaît clairement que
la droite n'a eu de cesse de développer
les outils et les procédures de nature à
répondre
au défi majeur que représente l'égalité
salariale hommes femmes
alors que la gauche demeure
malheureusement dans l'incantatoire
l'amélioration de la situation de
millions de femmes ne saurait se
contenter de slogans ayant à coeur de
nous adresser à toutes les femmes
ce quelles que soient leurs conditions
nous avons souhaité qu'elle puisse
investir en nombre les conseils
d'administration pouvez vous nous
indiquer monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures complémentaires le
gouvernement entend promouvoir pour
améliorer les dispositifs en place et
assurer l'égalité professionnelle hommes
femmes en matière de politique salariale
notamment je vous remercie
merci mes chers collègues pour nous
répond me parlait de monsieur et rigueur
mis du travail de la solidarité et de la
fonction publique
messieurs le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs même
la sénatrice isabelle debré d'abord
permettez-moi de me réjouir du de la
réunion de la commission des affaires
sociales il y a sur les 2 dernières
journées avec muguette dini et le
rapporteur dominique leclerc que je
salue et vous vos propositions madame la
sénatrice il ya eu des avancées très
importantes lors de la commission des
affaires sociales je le dis des avancées
très fortes qui font que ce texte
sortira du sénat comme un texte
améliorée amendé changé par la
commission et j'imagine monsieur le
président du sénat au moment évidemment
du débat général qui nous attend la
semaine prochaine et les semaines
suivantes
nous avons fait avancer les choses sur
les handicapés nous avons fait avancer
les choses sur les chômeurs les chômeurs
seniors
nous avons fait avancer les choses sur
nombre de sujets nous avons devant nous
d'autres sujets qu'il faut que nous
traitions même la sénatrice vous avez
raison à partir du moment où on décrit
la situation de façon exacte où on
décrit la vraie situation est pas une
fausse situation c'est difficile
d'apporter des réponses si la situation
n'est pas bien décrit qu'est ce qui se
passe en ce qui concerne les femmes est
un sujet qui préoccupe bien évidemment
notre majorité j'imagine aussi bien sûr
l'opposition
nous devons d'abord considérer que ce
n'est pas une question de trimestre
ce n'est pas aujourd'hui une question de
prix mais ça peut l'être encore sur les
quelques années qui viennent mais dans
bientôt notamment pour les femmes nées
dans les années 1956 elles auront le
même nombre de trimestres que les hommes
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
dispositifs qui ont été votées par les
majorités qui se sont succédés notamment
parce que lorsqu'on a des enfants on a
deux ans de bonification de deux
trimestres lorsqu'on s'arrête parce
qu'on a pris un congé parental
on a également des bonifications s'est
pris en compte au fond dans le calcul de
la de la retraite il faut le dire et les
femmes nées après les années cinquante
six vont au fur et à mesure du temps
avoir plus de trimestres que les hommes
donc la question c'est pas uniquement le
problème du trimestre les période hachée
laits carrière écourtée ou où les
carrières séquencé à cause des enfants à
cause de charges familiales
supplémentaires elles sont prises en
compte
déjà en ce qui concerne le temps partiel
qu'il ya plus de femmes que d'hommes qui
travaillent à temps partiel
c'est parfois voulu c'est aussi parfois
subi vous le savez très bien madame
debré il suffit aujourd'hui de
travailler à mi temps avec un à la
moitié d'un smic pour en réalité valider
une année entière et donc le temps
partiel est déjà intégrée dans les
systèmes de solidarité de la retraite je
voulais le dire car cela n'est pas
suffisamment su nous devrons peut-être
aller plus loin et notamment essayer de
régler ce problème majeur est scandaleux
dans la société du xxième siècle
française c'est l'inégalité salariale
c'est celle là qui provoque l'inégalité
de retraite
merci monsieur le ministre à paroles est
maintenant notre collègue jean pierre
sueur pour le groupe socialiste devait
la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
garde des sceaux dans l' affaire
bettencourt il apparaît indispensable
que soit nommé un juge d'instruction
indépendant
j'ai pris connaissance de ce que vous
avez déclaré à l'assemblée nationale
mardi
si j'ai bien compris vous avez dit en
substance que vous ne pouviez rien que
vous étiez spectatrice et que vous
regardiez passer les trains nous ne
partageons pas cette conception de votre
rôle
madame la ministre d'état à partir du
moment où il n'y a pas de juge
d'instruction indépendant
il ya la place ouverte pour toutes les
suspicions dans une affaire qui implique
des personnages éminents et pourrait
impliquer des personnages éminents
madame le garde des sceaux monsieur le
procureur courroye refuse la nomination
d'un juge d'instruction
monsieur le procureur général de
nanterre refuse aussi une seule personne
a la possibilité d'agir
vous nous ne vous demandons pas madame
le garde des sceaux d'intervenir dans
une affaire en cours
nous vous demandons en vertu de votre
fonction et ce qualité de garantir
l'indépendance de la justice dans une
affaire en cours
à cet égard fait sans précédent monsieur
jean louis nadal qui vous le savez est
le premier magistrat du parquet dans ce
pays procureur général près la cour de
cassation a déclaré qu'il était
nécessaire de désigner que soit nommé un
juge d'instruction
bien sûr indépendant et que c'était
nécessaire pour l'exercice des droits de
la défense dont vous êtes aussi la 40
donc madame la ministre notre seule
notre question est très simple
premièrement qu'elle
conclusion tirez vous de la déclaration
de monsieur jean louis nadal
deuxièmement allez vous enfin vous
exprimer clairement sur ce sujet et
prendre les initiatives nécessaires et
qui peuvent l'être
vous pouvez le faire de telle manière qu
un juge d'instruction indépendant soit
nommé dans ce dossier car nous le devons
vous le devez à la clarté à
l'indépendance de la justice dans cette
affaire très sensible
merci pour votre réponse sur le fond
parce que nous espérons que vous allez
rompre avec la langue de bois que nous
avons entendus à l'assemblée nationale
merci pour vos réponses
la parole est à madame michèle alliot
marie ministre d'état garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice et des libertés
vous avez la parole madame le ministre
d'état merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sûr je n'ai pas l'habitude de
manier la langue de bois contrairement à
ce que vous dites et je pense aussi que
connaissant votre honnêteté
intellectuelle lorsque l'on cite le
procureur général de la cour de
cassation il faut le site et en entier
et d'une façon précise
d'abord le procureur général près la
cour de cassation a dit une chose c'est
que il n'y avait pas lieu
en l'état de saisir la cour de justice
de la république ce que ces repas avait
demandé je conçois que cela déçoivent
mais il faut le rappeler
deuxièmement il a dit qu'il souhaitait
que l' enquête continue c'est la moindre
des choses et c'est bien le cas nous le
voyons
troisièmement le procureur a émis un
avis il a donné un avis sur le code
procédurales le mieux à même selon lui
de
préserver des droits pour la défense
à partir de là monsieur le sénateur il
faut aussi rappeler un certain nombre de
règles
le parquet peut dans tous les cas faire
le choix d'ouvrir une instruction
judiciaire comme il peut choisir de
poursuivre lui même l'enquète ce choix
lui appartient et il ne saurait en aucun
cas faire l'objet de pressions
politicienne
je ne vois pas et je vous le dis très
clairement comme j'ai pensé le dire très
clairement à l'assemblée nationale je ne
vois pas ce qui en l'état justifierait
que quiconque sim ici dans des enquêtes
qui sont en cours d'ailleurs ce que je
note c'est que ce serait une totale
nouveauté
monsieur sueur j'ai regardé ce qui
s'était passé depuis dix ans et depuis
dix ans il n'y a jamais eu et depuis 10
ans je précise bien il n'y a jamais eu
une intervention du ministre de la
justice dans une enquête
et dieu sait si des enquêtes impliquant
deux hautes personnalités ont souvent eu
lieu alors moi je respecte monsieur
sueur l'indépendance de la justice et
j'ai moi beaucoup de considérations pour
les magistrats
beaucoup trop pour m'immiscer dans les
procédures et si je vous ai bien compris
monsieur sueur il ya quand même quelque
chose qui m'étonne un tout petit peu
vous me demandez pour garantir
l'indépendance des procureurs de leur
donner des ordres
ça me paraît pour le moins étrange et en
tous les cas sa mère n'est pas ma
conception vous ne pouvait à la fois
loué l'indépendance des magistrats
lorsque leur décision vous convient et
la critique et lorsqu'elle ne vous
convient pas je crois que ça n'est pas
ça l'indépendance je crois ou veux faire
insulte aux magistrats du parquet que
d'agir comme vous le faites et bien
c'est peut-être votre conception de la
justice
mais ça n'est certainement pas la mienne
monsieur sûr
sous la mainmise d'état mes chers
collègues en ont fini avec les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h15
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement on se
retrouve tout de suite en direct du
sénat pour notre nouvelle émission on
refait la séance et autour de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
dont vous venez de suivre un instant la
séance et bien sûr avec les grands faits
du jour nous allons revenir tout de
suite avec nos invités
les sénateurs les ministres qui ont
participé à cette séance si on commence
tout de suite avec hervé maurey bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour
cette première on refait la séance
sénateurs centristes vous êtes intervenu
tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle sur la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
il ya eu de lecture à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat
beaucoup de tension maintenant au tour
de la commission mixte paritaire qui
doit se réunir entre les deux chambres
pour se mettre d'accord sur ce texte
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure votre
collègue radical mesures fortes à son
dire que le sénat dans cette affaire et
piétiné vous êtes d'accord avec lui
écoutez ce que j'observe c'est
qu'effectivement le texte tel qu'il est
sorti du sénat a été considérablement
modifié pour ne pas dire plus par
l'assemblée nationale et donc moi je
voulais déjà savoir si le gouvernement
avait décidé de convoquer une commission
mixte paritaire ce que vous disiez à
l'instant que ça allait se produire
mais alors qu'il est présent du sénat
arrive lancé sûrement plus que moi mais
alors qu'il est en tout cas je ne sais
pas si le gouvernement a décidé de de
convoquer une commission mixte paritaire
et comme l'avait très bien exprimé le
président du sénat moi je pense qu'il
faut éviter cette commission mixte
paritaire et qu'il faut que le dialogue
se poursuive entre les deux assemblées
effectivement gérard larcher le
président du sénat nous a rejoint merci
d'être avec nous après cette séance des
questions d'actualité
monsieur le président on a entendu un
plusieurs
vos collègues sénateurs dans l'hémicycle
interrogé aujourd'hui le gouvernement
sur cette réforme des collectivités il
ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
aujourd'hui sur la troisième mi-temps
finalement autour de ce texte alors
commission mixte paritaire où le
troisième lecture d'abord c'est un texte
important et au travers de son
questionnement du sénateur maurey a
exprimé d'ailleurs comme le sénateur
fortassin envoyés sur tous les bancs le
sentiment que cette réforme importante
elle devait s'inspirer des débats qui
ont existé dans chacune des assemblées
notamment de l'assemblée qui a la
mission constitutionnelle de représenter
et les collectivités territoriales
alors naturellement dans une lecture
stricte de la constitution une seule
assemblée l'assemblée nationale un seul
groupe qui a la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale peut adopter la réforme et
j'allais dire c'est la loi fondamentale
en même temps je ne peux pas imaginer
que nous n'ayons pas le dialogue
nécessaire pour arriver à un texte de
convergence donc de compromis mais il
n'y a rien de négatif dans le terme de
compromis je dois pouvoir vous apporter
puisque j'ai reçu au cours de la séance
je viens de signer à quelques instants
l'accusé de réception
le gouvernement envisage chance d'avoir
fixé la date la réunion d'une commission
mixte paritaire
quelque sorte que leur réservent à
public sénat et au sénateur maurey
puisque tout à l'heure à la fin du texte
j'ai indiqué qu'il m'apparaissait
nécessaire d'annoncer même sens la date
que le gouvernement ait pris cette
décision
or il est vrai que j'avais une première
réponse à la j'ai une première réponse
sur le fait qu'il y ait une commission
mixte paritaire et je souscris
naturellement tout à fait à ce que vient
de dire le président du sénat on ne peut
pas imaginer qu'un texte qui concerne
les collectivités locales soient
adoptées sans qu'il le soit adoptée
également par le par le sénat même si
constitutionnellement l'assemblée
nationale le pourrait ce serait un très
mauvais signal envoyé aux collectivités
locales et je pense que ça fragiliserait
la réforme et le gouvernement lui-même
ni groupes politiques au sénat gérard
larcher demande une concertation avant
cette commission
elle rappelait chez un de vos confrères
la semaine dernière à skis et ce
dialogue et c'était coutu mutuelle je
pense que il faut notamment qu'entre les
rapporteurs la commission des lois de
chacune des assemblées il ya un vrai
travail en profondeur au qu'elles soient
associés les responsables politiques de
l'ensemble des groupes notamment au céda
je pense aux groupes de la majorité
ce travail en profondeur il doit être
conduit en tous les cas comme président
du sénat j'y serai particulièrement
attentif c'est à dire vous allez
recevoir tous les présidents des groupes
politiques ce n'est pas moi sur le toit
mais naturellement je serai attentif je
sais que vous êtes attentifs à ces
questions là est ce que vous pensez
qu'un accord en commission mixte est
possible arrêt juge de rien je souhaite
qu'il y ait un vrai dialogue
une vraie écoute parce que sur le bloc
communal il reste quelques questions
même si globalement il ya des
convergences à quai sur les communes
nouvelles par exemple est une vraie
question
d'ailleurs aussi porté par l'association
des maires de france la question des
compétences nécessite une véritable
rencontre
et puis il y a notamment la carte pour
un certain nombre de départements voilà
des sujets qui sont sur la table mais je
fais confiance aux rapporteurs au
président et pour que tous ces sujets
sans faux semblants sans faux fuyant
soient examinés et il est demeuré sur le
terrain comment vous sentez les choses
est ce que cette réforme elle est encore
appliquée finalement après toutes les
modifications intervenues entre
l'assemblée et le sénat
sur le terrain c'est vrai que la version
qui est sorti de l'assemblée suscite
certaines inquiétudes particulièrement
par rapport aux communes nouvelles
rappaz autres détails techniques mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui j'ai rencontré
depuis que le texte a été adopté à
l'assemblée au coup de mer qui sont
inquiets par ce nouveau dispositif et
choix que c'est un point important qu'il
faudra essayer de faire évoluer et comme
je le disais tout à l'heure il faut le
faire je crois de manière honnête parce
qu'on voit beaucoup de responsables
politiques de l'opposition qui sur le
terrain dans des inaugurations dans des
manifestations alors c'est pas forcément
le lieu ni le moment
selon ce droit
faire peur aux élus locaux et ça je
trouve que c'est tout à fait regrettable
parce qu'on peut critiquer on peut ne
pas être d'accord ça m'arrive de l'être
même si chez la majorité mais il faut
toujours l'être sur des bases réelles et
ne pas mentir aux électeurs aux grands
électeurs pour leur faire peur je trouve
que ça ça n'est pas bien
très bien merci beaucoup et hervé maurey
d'avoir été avec nous on va aborder
peut-être l'autre sujet du jour et
notamment cette image dans l'hémicycle
tout à l'heure gérard larcher du groupe
communiste qui a brandi des pancartes
voilà on revoit cette image la retraite
à 60 ans alors le texte a été adopté
hier en commission des affaires sociales
le texte du rapporteur
maintenant place au débat dans
l'hémicycle déjà une première chose vous
avez un peu allongé le temps du débat
hier en conférence des présidents
conférence des présidents hier deux
examinions pour la deuxième fois nous
l'avions fait au début de la session
extraordinaire
l'organisation de nos débats nous avons
confirmé donc deux semaines consacrées
en ouvrant 81 eur pour le débat
parlementaire
aussi bien la discussion générale que
les amendements que les explications de
vote soit déjà 15 heures de plus que la
réalité l'assemblée nationale je crois
qu'il faut que le débat ait lieu qu'ils
aient lieu sur le fond que ce débat et
doit être un vrai échange est l'occasion
je le dis dori chiant le texte dans le
sens de l'équité mais ça ça appartient
maintenant au rapporteur à la commission
les affaires sociales sa présidente et
aux sénateurs mais parce qu'on se pose
effectivement la question des marges de
manoeuvre maintenant du sénat sur ce
texte ait pas eu beaucoup de
modifications apportées en commission
est pas tout à fait exact où se regarder
la situation des chômeurs de longue
durée
arrive en salles et dire au delà de
toute indemnisation
c'est un vrai sujet la situation aussi
face à l'amiante et notamment le risque
qui était celui du report de l'âge de
deux années en ce qui concerne la
médecine du travail
il ya aussi un débat sur le système
et ce débat aura lieu en séance de même
qu'il va y avoir un débat sur la
situation notamment d'un certain nombre
de conjoints ayant eu trois enfants
principalement des femmes ayant eu des
carrières hachées
la question du temps partiel même abordé
par le ministre va faire l'objet d'un
certain nombre d'interrogations leur
apportera encore des auditions à faire
ce sera vraiment le 5 octobre jusqu'au
dernier moment et c'est normal c'est
naturel il y a aussi des questions de
chiffrage qu'il faut encore affiner
sachez que vous en parlait déjà depuis
un certain temps on ne les avait pas
encore on en a mais parfois il faut
qu'il soit un peu plus convergents donc
je crois que la commission fait
totalement son travail et que c'est bien
et que c'est la manière de travailler du
sénat l'opposition entendent déposé un
certain nombre d'amendements notamment
le groupe socialiste en début de semaine
prochaine vous avez perdu nos structures
la part de l'opposition dont je crois
pas qu'ils aient les amendements c'est
normal
le parlement est là pour débattre pour
armand des pour faire évoluer majorité
opposition et ils y ont leur place
j'espère tout simplement que ce sera
vraiment au coeur du texte que nous
serons et je fais plutôt confiance à mes
collègues pour que nous échappions à la
tentation qui existe toujours il y aura
des moments de tension il y aura des
moments forts c'est légitime parce que
c'est le reflet tout simplement de la
vie politique et des réalités sur le
terrain
elle est une ou deux petites questions
de politique générale françois fillon
qui évoque le bon timing pour un
changement de premier ministre à dire
une fois que les grandes réformes sont
accomplies est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec lui coûter la décision de chambre
en premier ministre appartient au
président de la république et à lui seul
mais ce que là on est dans le bon timing
en tous les cas mais dans un timing
annoncé depuis longtemps alors je pense
qu'ils pourraient bien l'arrivée
annoncée depuis trop longtemps
écoutez ça appartient au président de la
république en tous les cas je crois que
il va falloir que le temps suspend son
vol
si on le livre de martin hirsch et eu
beaucoup de réactions ici au sénat on a
parlé de délation vous êtes d'accord
avec non simplement j'ai rappelé à ce
que chacun respecte l'obligation de
réserve
kissi atouf aux fonctionnaires sur des
sujets de cette nature notamment dans la
commission de transparence de la vie
politique
je le dis parce que ici nous avons mis
en place au sénat depuis une année un
comité de déontologie que nous avons
eues à gérer un certain nombre de
dossiers et j'observe que dans cette
maison on respecte les principes qui
sont les principes qui sont ceux de la
haute fonction publique je souhaiterais
que ce soit respectée partout notamment
sur des sujets qui est la transparence
de la vie politique
voilà pourquoi je ne vous cache pas
avoir interrogé le vice-président du
conseil d'état sur ce sujet et quand
françois hollande se prononce pour une
interdiction totale d'un cumul entre une
activité d'un parlementaire et
l'exercice d'un métier ça vous semble
possible à côté ça sujet ce que nous
avons abordés c'est un sujet sur lequel
le comité de déontologie présidé par
robert badinter est en train de
travailler le sénat j'aperçois
secrétaire du sénat françois fortassin
qui nous a rejoint examinera le 13
octobre prochain
ces dossiers c'est sujet sur lequel nous
avons déjà travaillé depuis maintenant
près d'une année une toute petite
dernière question il ya cette une du
magazine newsweek qui fait couler
beaucoup d'encre en france où on voit le
président nicolas sarkozy présentait
finalement comme un petit peu le chef de
file d'une droite nationaliste populiste
en europe ça nous a choqués cette une
oui parce que c'est les photos de
l'extrême et quand on accuse quelqu'un
d'extrême ici il faut éviter des
extrémistes soi même et je trouve
inadmissible ce genre de photographies
et ce genre de propos je le dit
extrêmement clairement et chacun que les
mon sens de la mesure
très bien merci beaucoup gérard larcher
d'avoir été avec nous pour cette
première dont refait la séance
on poursuit ces questions avec
maintenant le sénateur radical françois
fortassin qui nous a rejoint bonjour
merci d'être avec nous avec nous on vous
a entendu tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle sur la réforme des
collectivités territoriales vous avez eu
des mots assez forts vous avez dit le
sénat et piétiné dans cette histoire
effectivement je n'ai pas voulu traiter
due forme de l'art de la réforme tout ça
n'était pas le lieu puis dans le land de
tandem partie n'était pas question de le
faire par contre c'est vrai que une
réforme territoriale qui se ferait sans
l'accord du sénat me paraît être quelque
chose de totalement aberrant on avait un
texte que j'ai qualifiée d'extravagant à
20,2 réel et de surréaliste c'est vrai
que le sénat a beaucoup travaillé mais
ça n'a pas servi semble-t-il à grand
chose
est ce que je trouve pour ma part le
plus choquant c'est que la mission belot
et fait un travail remarquable animée
par notre collègue claude belot et
ensuite il y avait des sénateurs de
toutes sensibilités il s'était beaucoup
déplacé sur le terrain
il avait fait naître beaucoup
d'espérance dans la mesure où on pensait
que le sénat sur le garant des
collectivités territoriales et surtout
de l'autonomie de chacune de ces
collectivités territoriales et on voit
qu'en définitive ce travail a été foulée
aux pieds il a été jeté par dessus bord
ça n'est pas très digne et nombreux
sénateurs
quel que soit notre sensibilité nous
sommes quand même relativement dépité
selon le cas très en colère comme j'ai
eu le cas de le dire ou résigné j'ai eu
effectivement toute cette réflexion de
fond avec la mission belot dont vous
venez d'évoquer sur la réforme des
collectivités territoriales au sénat il
ya quand même une double lecture à
l'assemblée et au sénat
donc il ya eu tout un temps assez long
de procédure législative c'est pas
suffisant
non mon avis est passé pas suffisant
parce que le le texte n'a pas été
conduit comme ils auraient dû l'être me
semble-t-il par par le gouvernement ici
je reconnais pour ma part que le
ministre qui est qui avait en charge de
cela a fait un certain nombre
d'ouvertures mai à l'assemblée nationale
il n'en a pas été ainsi et on a le
sentiment que c'est une sorte de rouleau
compresseur qui est passé en quelque
sorte que je lis bull je pèse mes mots
mais en disant que le sénateur que je
suis se savent en tout petit peu humide
y ait par la façon dont les choses se
sont passées à écouter on est sûr en
tout cas le sénat peut-être son
président vous entendu tout à leur merci
beaucoup monsieur martin sain d'avoir
été avec nous on va parler maintenant du
budget du projet de loi de finances pour
2011 qui a été annoncé et présenté cette
semaine par les ministres christine
lagarde et françois baroin bonjour
philippe marini vous êtes ici au sénat
le rapporteur général du budget déjà 7
peut-être bonne nouvelle venue de la
croissance ces chiffres
qu'a annoncé françois baroin en avant
première cet après midi les chiffres de
l'insee +16 la croissance en 2010 ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle de toute façon
il vaut toujours mieux affiché une
prévision modeste et constater que la
réalité est meilleur moi je ne cesse de
le dire à nos gouvernements successifs
depuis de nombreuses années et ces deux
produits en 2011 qui sont assez contesté
notamment par td sont testés et en
revenant à 2 % ce qui est le taux de
croissance potentielle de l'économie
pour 2011 lors de la réunion de
brégançon fin août je pense que le
gouvernement a bien agi maintenant pour
2012 et 2013
à mon avis serait plus raisonnable d'en
rester à ces 2 % nicole bricq
bah écoutez les hypothèses de croissance
sur lesquelles sont faites
le budget 2011 comme la prévision de
programmation des finances publiques
jusqu'en 2013 sont quand même très
aléatoire et la méthode qui consiste à
préfigurer un taux de croissance alors
qu'on sait très bien que le premier
semestre 2011 quand même être assez
difficile
je crois qu'elle n'est pas bonne sur ce
budget 2011 qui a donc été présenté en
conseil des ministres cette semaine
nicole bricq
on parle le gouvernement capable d'un
budget de rupture vous la voyez où il a
résulté ce que j'observe c'est que quand
même c'est un budget préélectoral faut
quand même le dire c'est le dernier
budget utile avant 2012 et que
quelque part créé doctorale quelque part
on ne renonce à rien des bêtises de 2007
et la crise a bon dos mais tout déficit
et dette était quand même en grosse
partie antérieure à la crise et on
prétend faire payer la crise à tout le
monde
alors ce n'est pas vrai ce sont les plus
modestes qui vont la payer au travers de
ce budget parmi les beats les bêtises
que vous évoquez ce que vous parler du
bouclier fiscal entre autres ça c'est un
symbole c'est un tabou et un totem de
680 millions d'euros
mais il ya tout le reste il ya tout
quand même tout le paquet fiscal de 2007
et des budgets successifs le bouclier
fiscal fille miley serait qui reste très
critiqué y compris dans votre camp à
droite pourquoi le maintenir à tout prix
mais dans cette période de reprise nous
avons besoin des capitaux donner un
signal très négatif aux détenteurs de
capitaux inciter à la fuite des capitaux
se serait travailler contre la
croissance je crois aussi mais nicole
bricq a rappelé le montant du bouclier
fiscal par rapport à l'enjeu global
c'est-à-dire faire passer le déficit de
l'état de 150 milliards d'euros à 90
milliards d'euros que cette question du
bouclier fiscal
elle ne doit pas cacher tout le reste
d'un an et parler de l'essentiel et pour
ma part je ne trouve pas que ce budget
soit pré électorale
même si nous sommes en fin de mandature
il est courageux car il n'hésite pas
dans le vif des débats assez loin selon
vous
bouquins chaude il avoue rester plus
loin mais il faut faire très attention à
l'équilibré entre l'activité
la reprise de l'activité et d'autre part
la nécessaire réduction du déficit
l'ajustement budgétaire mais ce qui
importe pour moi c'est que nous soyons
crédibles dans la trajectoire des trod
et 3% en 2013 et mon inquiétude à cet
égard elle pèse plus sur 2012 et sur
2013 que sur 2011
je pense que quand même il ya un
problème aussi pour 2011
parce que c'est une reprise très très
fragile
et quand on parle des chiffres de la
croissance pour 2010 puisque là on les a
en grande partie
vous savez très bien que c'est une
reprise technique comme on dit dans la
mesure où les entreprises ont
reconstitué leurs stocks et que de toute
façon nous avons un problème très lourd
est assez particulier à la france et un
chômage très lourd et qui coûte très
cher et je pense que les entreprises
vont rattraper leurs pertes de
productivité pendant la crise et qu on
le paiera très lourdement en non
rentrées de fiscalité on parle de plus
en plus une faillite d'une convergence
de nos systèmes fiscaux avec l'allemagne
pourtant on n'a pas du tout le même
modèle que ça vous semble faisable c'est
tout à fait logique parce que
l'harmonisation fiscale en europe est
bloquée totalement
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de possibilités
crédible de se mettre d'accord à 27 sur
la fiscalité
or notre problème à nous c'est bien
celui de la compétitivité de nos
entreprises c'est de travailler à armes
égales avec l'allemagne certes à
certains égards nous avons fait des
choix structurelles différents mais il
n'en reste pas moins que nous sommes
d'abord des états avec une protection
sociale importante avec une vision
économique beaucoup plus que financière
et nous avons du point de vue de notre
univers juridiques et économiques
beaucoup de choses en commun
donc si le rhum est bloquée imposer le
faire du milli dû plier par exemple les
verts du bilatéral oui parce que la cour
constitutionnelle de karlsruhe
il y à déjà très longtemps à considérer
que ce type d'impôt était spoliateurs de
la propriété privée et est ce que
philippe marini vous approuve riez le
contrôle a priori par bruxelles de nos
budgets nationaux
mais si nous réalisons l'ajustement
jetair donc si nous sommes sérieux si
nous sommes capables d'inspirer
confiance bruxelles nous félicitera si
al'inverse nous laissons filer les
choses si nous ne sommes pas sérieux
dans notre gestion
bruxelles ne tapera sur les ongles donc
c'est à nous de nous placer dans la
position où en europe nous inspirerons
confiance il ne faut pas se livrer à des
manoeuvres d'arrière-garde et pacte de
stabilité ou pas maastricht ou pas quand
on a une dette largement supérieure à 13
100 milliards d'euros il faut être très
sérieux nicole bricq pour conclure sur
ce point écoute et on a aussi on a fait
les choses un peu à l'envers
le groupe d'un drone paye et dictent
déjà des sanctions pour les pays qui ne
rentreraient pas dans les clous du pacte
de stabilité et sommes donc marché
unique budget convergents mais on ne se
pose pas le problème de la fiscalité on
ne se pose pas ce n'est pas sérieux de
la part de nos dirigeants de ne pas
défendre ce gouvernement économique que
nous réclamons au moins au niveau de la
zone euro très bien écouter merci
beaucoup à tous les deux est revenu sur
notre plateau je vous laisse rejoindre
la séance je crois que vous avez tous
les d'un amendement à défendre merci
beaucoup d'avoir été en direct avec nous
on va faire un petit point avec le
sénateur socialiste jean-pierre sueur
qui va prendre votre place nicole bricq
voilà jean pierre serre qui est
intervenu tout à l'heure en séance sur
les conflits d'intérêts sur l' affaire
woerth bettencourt vous avez interpellé
jean pierre sueur la garde des sceaux en
lui demandant de ne pas être trop langue
de bois
comment vous l'avez quand j'ai eu droit
une tranche de langue de bois
supplémentaires je lui dis à l'assemblée
nationale vraiment vous n'avez pas
répondu
la question c'est que le plus haut
magistrat de france du parc et monsieur
jean louis nadal procureur général près
la cour de cassation s'exprime c'est
rare c'est sans précédent en disant je
recommande qui est un juge d'instruction
dans cette affaire je la garde des
sceaux intervienne dans les affaires
judiciaires en cours je lui ai dit
vous avez bien entendu je lui ai dit je
ne vous demande pas d'intervenir
je vous demande de garantir
l'indépendance de la justice c'est tout
à fait différent
je ne demande pas à madame alliot-marie
de donner des instructions sur le fond
de cette question je le lui demandent
certainement pas ça et d'ailleurs c'est
un peu étrange parce que l sa
philosophie elle a exprimé à beaucoup de
reprises c'est qu'il est normal que le
garde des sceaux donne des instructions
au parquet donc ce qui est bizarre c'est
qu'elle trouve normal que le garde des
sceaux donne des instructions au parquet
sauf dans la sphère bettencourt où elle
le juge même pas opportun d'ouvrir la
bouche pour dire ce serait pas mal qu'il
y ait un juge d'instruction indépendant
et pourquoi vous n'avez pas interroger
la garde des sceaux peut-être cet
après-midi ou du moins le gouvernement
sur la une du monde le monde qui accuse
cet après-midi matignon d'avoir dérogé à
la loi pour procéder à des écoutes
illégales parce que j'avais prévu la
question à l'avance le monde est sorti
est bon ce n'était pas ce n'était pas
prévu et je n'avais pas étudié le sujet
parce que le monde il arrive une demi
heure avant la séance et que ce n'est
pas très sérieux d'improviser sur un
sujet qu'on ne connaît pas tandis que l'
affaire bettencourt quand même tout le
monde voit bien que ce monsieur courroye
qui décide lui-même que seul lui même
doit exercer tous les pouvoirs au mépris
des droits de la défense puisque quand
vous avez une procédure d' enquête
préliminaire
il n'y a pas de respect des droits de la
défense il ya là quand même quelque
chose de choquant par rapport à
l'indépendance de la justice
j'ai remarqué d'ailleurs que j'ai été
écouté dans un très grand silence et je
sais qu'il ya un malaise par rapport à
tout cela on voit bien que ça ne marche
pas et que la question et je finirai là
dessus si vous le permettez dans cette
affaire où des personnages éminents sont
impliqués et ont peut être d'autres
personnages éminents pourraient être
impliqués il y a quand même la volonté
que tout ça soit très cadré
très bien merci merci jean pierre sueur
d'être vous aussi venu sur notre plateau
cet après midi on va finir cette tranche
dont on refait la séance avec deux
femmes isabelle debré a maintenant deux
femmes exactement isabelle debré bonjour
merci d'être là catherine tasca
merci à vous aussi d'être avec nous vous
êtes toutes les deux intervenus dans
l'hémicycle sur la question des
retraites le texte a donc été adoptée on
a parlé tout à l'heure avec le président
du sénat gérard larcher en commission il
ya plusieurs mois qu'ils sont élevées
pour souligner quand même l'absence dans
les débats catherine tasca du groupe
socialiste se ce sont des des sourds ou
des aveugles parce que le grenoble
entendu le groupe communiste et
socialiste
le groupe socialiste s'est totalement
engagés sur ce dossier bien évidemment
tout comme d'ailleurs il est présent
dans les manifestations qui rassemblent
comme vous le savez beaucoup de monde
contre ce projet de réforme est ce que
vous avez eu cette impression isabelle
debré non c'est vrai que le groupe
socialiste s'est peut-être pas beaucoup
exprimé mais c'est pas pour autant que
ils vont pas s'exprimer vous savez moi
je suis c'est pas je pense que ça doit
dépasser les clivages politiques je
crois que franchement là on s'aperçoit
que les retraites c'est un c'est un
dossier national
nous devons sauver notre retraite par
répartition nous devons et nous voulons
sauver notre retraite par répartition
donc je crois que c'est pas il faut pas
faire un clivage gauche droite il faut
qu'on travaille tous ensemble et qu'on
arrive à proposer des solutions on le
sait très bien on sait qu'il la faut
cette réforme
je crois que personne ne nie qu'il faut
réformer mais nous y mettons n'êtes pas
d'accord nous y mettons des conditions
en particulier que la charge de cette
réforme soit mieux répartie façon plus
équitable puisque aujourd'hui vous le
savez 85 % de la charge repose sur les
salariés alors que le capital ne
contribue qu'à 15%
c'est un écart qui devient injustifiable
dans dans la situation économique du
du pays donc nous voulons une réforme
plus équitable et je dois dire que mais
c'est beaucoup la méthode du président
sarkozy il a réussi à polariser le débat
sur les deux dates sur les deux âges
butoir le 60 62 65 67 ans c'est vrai que
c'est à un aspect du problème mais ce
n'est qu'un aspect la vraie question le
sait bien c'est la durée des de
cotisation ce sont les annuités or ceux
qui aujourd'hui fait problème c'est
qu'une très grande partie des actifs
n'entre dans l'adjectif que très tard et
nous avons évoqué tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle problème des stages pour les
jeunes et nous voyons bien que rien
n'est fait pour faciliter l'entrée des
jeunes dans la vie active et à l'autre
bout de la vie beaucoup de salariés sont
éliminés de la vie active entre 50 et 55
final c'est ça le problème de fond alors
sur ces deux points il avait d'abord et
surtout sur effectivement il y a
beaucoup de sujets sur les retraites
nous sommes en train de les traiter les
uns après les autres nous avons fait des
avancées considérables concernant les
personnes handicapées
concernant les chômeurs d'un certain âge
tout ce qui touche la mer nous sommes en
train de travailler bien sûr sur les
femmes
ça je crois que c'est un dossier pas eu
d'avancée notable en commission sur
cette question d'exemple réseau des
réseaux ouverts ce jour en séance et
nous pour ce qui est des dépenses et
nous avons pour l'instant examinées les
exams l'aîné pardon les amendements qui
sont de la commission mais je peux vous
dire que à titre personnel en tant que
pourtant vice présent la commission j'ai
des amendements que nous allons il faut
connaître le travail en fait de
commissions vous avez des amendements
qu'arrive une première fois qu'ils sont
des amendements de commissions vous avez
après ce qu'on appelle les amendes en
extérieur et dans les amendements
extérieur il y aura beaucoup d'un moment
ump et même de personnes qui
appartiennent à la commission je suis
moi dans la commission j'ai des
amendements qui vont arriver
donc il nous faut un petit peu de temps
parce que il y avait des amendements
concernant justement à la situation des
femmes ou des mères de famille plus
exactement des mères de famille le
problème c'est qu'il faut faire très
attention à la rédaction des amendements
pour qui
ouah recevable qu'ils soient pas qu'ils
soient recevables d'un poil de
constitutionnel et vis-à-vis de l'europe
donc c'est pour ça que nous avons un
petit problème de rédaction nous sommes
en train de travailler sur ces
amendements
et je peux vous assurer que le groupe
ump proposera des amendements on va
terminer sur cette question catherine
tasca institutionnels quand même visait
à valoriser le travail en commissions et
c'eût été l'intérêt du sénat et de la
commission compétente de donner des
signes forts d'avancé sur cette question
qui doit absolument être traités on sait
bien que les femmes aujourd'hui qui sont
sous payés pendant leur vie
professionnelle ont des retraites des
niveaux très inférieurs à ceux des
hommes
on sait aussi qu'avec le déplacement du
butoir des dates de 60 à 62 ans 65 à 67
ans ce sont les femmes qui vont être les
premières pénalisées
donc il y à bien au minimum à trouver
des solutions et nous avons fait des
propositions des solutions pour gérer la
transition
peut-être que dans dix ans les femmes
auront des parcours professionnels plus
proche de celui des hommes encore que on
demande à avoir parce que rien ne
s'annonce comme tel donc c'est un point
majeur et moi je regrette vraiment qu'en
commission
rien n'a été fait ce matin encore dans
l'hémicycle la loi sur l'organisation du
marché de l'électricité nous avions
suggéré que dans le nouvel organisme qui
va arbitrer les problèmes du marché
d'électricité
il y est
des femmes ça a été refusé donc on sent
bien qu'il ya sur ce sujet des annonces
des effets de manche si j'ose dire mais
peu d'actes concrets et même un vrai
freinage très bien mais coûte cher c'est
quand même vraiment très importante je
crois qu'aujourd'hui l'avancé quand même
c'est de faire en sorte que les congés
maternité soit pris en compte dans les
retraites ce qui n'avait jamais été le
cas jusqu'à aujourd'hui et d'autres
mesures bien sûr qu'ils vont qui vont
venir mais celle là est très très
importante pour les mères de famille les
culièrement ces points les ors de la
liste je peux dire que c'est un
amendement en commission en début
semaine et les mesures ponctuelles qui
concerne les femmes qui concerne les
handicapés ne contribueront pas à
changer l'équilibré général de la
réforme
oh c'est cet équilibre général je le
rappelle entre les salariés et le
capital qui doit être revue très bien
merci beaucoup catherine tasca merci
zabel debré merci d'avoir suivi cette
première émission on refait la séance
sur public sénat
très bonne après midi à tous sur la
chaîne parlementaire rendez vous autour
de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire à 19 heures avec michel
grossiord merci